joining us now Senate Judiciary
Committee Chairman Senator Lindsey
Graham senator a lot of this falls now
on your shoulders I see you laughing but
you know I've enjoy having joy listening
anything that you've heard me say that's
wrong no I mean do you know we're not
gonna try these people on cable
television we're gonna put it through
the rule of law right that's what you
want totally agree I believe in due
process two presentations absolutely and
you've been consistent on it here's what
I want to find out did they'd exonerate
Clinton because they had a political
bias did they ignore it all the facts
because that they indict her they know
she can't beat Trump and they weren't a
trump to lose was the
counterintelligence investigation a
backdoor way of spying on Trump there's
real no evidence of working with Russia
they just used an excuse was the FISA
warrant obtained unlawfully based on
fraudulent documentation to surveil the
campaign those are the things that I
think you want to know about and I want
to know about what will you do tell us
the steps that you will take you will
play great question a very pivotal role
here sir first thing you're going to do
is find out why they got a warrant
against Carter Paige if the dossier was
a bunch of garbage what did you have
beyond the dossier why didn't you listen
to Bruce or at the end of the day how
could you use this document that's
unverified to this day to get a warrant
on four different occasions
I want to find out all about that I want
to know if the email investigation was
basically dropped because they had a
political bias I want to know if the
counterintelligence investigation why
didn't you warn Trump that you thought
the Russians were trying to infiltrate
his campaign why didn't you tell me what
you told Einstein right well so the
reason I think they didn't tell him
about the Russians infiltrating his
campaign is that they wanted to
infiltrate his campaign not the Russians
all right senator I know that you have a
you know and by the way there are a lot
of good people that have been very
helpful in all this and and meadows and
Jordan and yeah and all these people you
now have the ability to make public and
the president will have the ability to
make public the FISA warrants the
302s the gang of eight information and
these other buckets the five buckets I
always talk about right how important is
it that the American people see that
besides the Muller you know conclusions
I've been pretty consistent I said I
thought Muller was the right guy to look
into the allegations against President
Trump he was a man of a law he had a
great reputation and I fought to make
sure he could do his job he has rendered
his verdict
there is no collusion now it's time to
look at how this got off the rails so
what am I going to do I'm going to use
every tool available to be disclosed as
much as I can without compromising
source and methods to make sure the
public understands how their president
could be accused of working with a
foreign government when there's real no
basis in fact this should scare
everybody did the investigators did the
prosecutors use the law for political
purposes if that turns out to be true
that is bigger than Watergate did they
try to take him down after he got
elected was there real effort to invoke
the death Amendment looks like I don't
know Shawn but nobody seems to give a
damn but me and you and a few other
people if it had been Republicans to
hiring Steele the spy on Clinton and
they use a dossier prepared by still
against Clinton associates that was a
bunch of political garbage it be front
page why senator ironically Russian lies
I think so I told Trump that I think the
dossier came for Russia mr. president if
you think the Russians are just out to
help you they're not they're out to
destroy America and they're certainly
using both campaigns you really had a
moment in the Cavanaugh case a lot
weighs on your investigation and your
pledge tonight is so important to
getting to the truth so this never
happens again sir thank you for being
with us thank you